Let's look at the solution
to our page size quiz.
Our physical memory's 2 GB.
Our page size is 4 kB.
How many page frames we have?
Well, a page frame is a place in
physical memory where a page might fit.
So, the number of frames is simply 2 GB,
the physical memory size,
divided by the page size.
The frame is the same size as a page
because it's basically a place for
a page to be in.
When we are doing things like this,
usually it's a lot easier to think
about this as what power of two is it.
So, 2 GB is 2 to the 31st bytes.
4 kB is 2 to the 12th bytes, so
we end up with 2 to the 19th frames,
so the answer here is 2 to the 19th.
How many entries do we
have in each page table?
We need one entry in a page table for
each page in the virtual memory.
So the answer here is 4
GB divided by 4 kB, and
that is 2 to the 20th, or
one mega entry as they would say.
Note that we need a separate
page table for each process.
Each process is 4 GB of virtual memory.
So each process in our system will
need a page table that is this large,
2 to the 20th or
slightly more than one million entries.